[Music]
12 36
okay we're going e4 i forgot to do 10
plus 5 but it's fine
all right so we're facing a scandi of
course we take
and um
yeah so multiple options in the scandi
d4
is far less common but also a good move
but of course everybody plays knight c3
so that's what we're going to do
so
um i want to teach you guys a a setup
against the scandi which is
quite uncommon and it's going to come
quite as a surprise to some people
most people play d4 some of you might uh
be aware of this trappy move b4
i'm gonna make a move which might cause
a lot of you to roll your eyes like is
this really that great
uh but hopefully i'll be able to show
you that it's an easy system
and it's one that's pretty heavy on on
good positional principles and that's
the move g3 preparing uh to fianchetto
and as you might imagine once you
fianchetto the knight comes to e2
in order to not obstruct the bishop now
it might seem like the bishop is also
biting on granite you know why are we
getting it to g2
and that's where the second component of
this setup is gonna come in this bishop
as you'll see assuming the game goes
along normal lines is actually going to
become a very good piece because white
is a plan
that it
that involves trying to break down the c
pawn
and get this bishop to
operate at its full potential
all right so for now we're just
developing castles
um d3 just all the normal developing
moves nothing much to say here
now once we complete our development
that's when i'll i'll show you guys the
main
plan associated with this line now
usually people play e6 i'm not as
familiar with the move e5 and
e5 could allow us to play d4 and
challenge the center okay bishop b4 is
not a great move because it in fact it
walks right into a move that we would
have played anyway
what am i talking about i mean it's a
natural reaction to bishop before
yeah e5 is a little bit loosey-goosey
yeah of course a3 does not threaten a
takes before but okay he takes anyway
all right so neither bc nor dc is worth
ruining the pawn structure we take with
the knight
and you might start thinking about what
it is that we're preparing with a3 what
is this enigmatic
plan
and if you ask yourself that in that way
you should be able to understand what
the plan is the plan is to ultimately
push this b pawn to b5
um and organize kind of a a classic
you could call it i suppose a minority
attack
although it's not similar to the
minority attack in the queens again but
mostly you're trying to get this bishop
to
fire on all cylinders bishop g4 okay
so we don't want to play f3 we
definitely don't want to play bishop f3
we want to play queen to e1
and later on we can chase the bishop
away with h3
thank you brigadier pudding for the
prime now another important note is
let's say black castles
are we necessarily in a huge rush to
play before and sometimes this is
forgotten by people
just because you know what your plan is
doesn't necessarily mean you have to do
it immediately it's totally fine to
complete your development first
and only
you know go through carry out the main
plan when you're ready and this is a
great example of that you could play b4
but i like a more patient approach with
d3 and who knows maybe black will do
something that will
uh necessitate an alternate approach you
don't want to
uh you know reveal your your hand too
soon especially when there's no way to
stop before i mean c5 is horrendous and
does our work for us not to mention it's
a blunder
yeah maybe bishop g5 first maybe we'll
want to attack on the kings on the uh
kings side now black's best move for his
knight b to d7 completing his
development which i assume is going to
be played
yeah i don't want to play bishop d2
though in a way bishop d2 is
counterproductive because
the problem with bishop d2 is that it
helps black's queen
get away from a5 right think about that
and that defeats part of the purpose of
b4 which is that it's a move with tempo
so definitely now we want to play b4
and b4 also opens up a a very attractive
at least to me developing square for the
bishop on b2 double fiance what is this
bishop going to be doing here it's going
to be applying pressure on the e5 of
course the knight on c3 eventually is
going to move
and that's an important uh
point to make a lot of people hesitate
to put a piece on a square where it's
covered by another one of your pieces
generally speaking that is not a problem
because ultimately you know that this
knight
is going to move either to e4 or maybe
it won't move
but the bishop has a lot of potential
energy to borrow you know the term that
i really like to use in such situations
no yeah so queen a6 is a very strange
move i assume he's trying to prevent b5
but this queen is going to be offsides
um and of course we can reinforce b5 by
playing a later a4
uh why not cake the bishop asks some of
you yeah gage three is totally fine i
don't necessarily see a reason for or
against it
uh the bishop is not truly bothering me
on g4
and one very sad let's
i don't really know to be honest i guess
i guess we can throw it in just for some
luft
and to see where he goes just to force
black to make a decision i i don't feel
strongly for or against h3 i think it's
fine but it's not necessary
and in fact i would
i wouldn't play it in a classical game
because it lets his bishop reposition to
a slightly better square what is the
bishop doing on f5 what might he later
be able to prepare who can tell me and
this is
you know not a mistake but
it's a little bit concerning later on if
he plays this correctly
so when black's bishop lands on f5 what
do we have to watch for
yeah we have to watch for e4 later on we
have a queen on e1 there is an x-ray
but of course e4 is not possible
immediately because we have one two
three four defenders and assuming the
bishop moves to f5 there's one two three
attackers and it's very hard for black
to reinforce that square one more time
because the queen is so out of the game
he can't get to e7 easily thank you vp
for the 25 months
okay bishop h5 is something i like to
see and now
let's complete our development with
bishop b2
i know that some of you might have been
attracted to bishop g5 but that's not a
dangerous move because black can go
knight bd70 cozy for anyway
which definitely doesn't make sense here
now one really interesting thing we
could do
just a little bit of practice in not
stopping the calculation prematurely
whenever you have a bishop on a long
diagonal you have to
sort of at least be aware of the
potential of building a battery so
imagine a future where the knight on f6
is gone from the board what becomes
possible and the knight on c3 is also
gone from the board what move becomes
possible let's do a little bit of
hypothetical thinking that's actually
going to turn to reality
queen c3 and queen c3 is a really nasty
battery it forces an incredibly
weakening move like f6
so how do you guys think we should
capture the spawn taking with the pawn
and then playing f4 e5 is one very
powerful approach
but
i like knight takes c4 which
probably in the grand scheme of things
is worse than dxe4 but i want to
emphasize
an idea
now do we take automatically with a plan
do we take automatically with a pawn
what do you guys say about bishop takes
c4
does bishop take c4 lose the bishop to
f5
no it does not
no it does not because of queen c3
setting a trap this is how you set traps
you make moves that are good on their
own merit
and i can almost guarantee you that f5
is gonna happen in fact probably pretty
fast after bishop takes e4
the same goes for moves like bishop f3
here we go queen c3 threatening mate and
in the event of f5 it's a total disaster
because
black's gonna lose that pawn
okay well this is
this is hard to predict rook takes e4
oh
gate
thanks for that
well i guess i was wrong what can i say
not a prophet
yeah that was unpredictable though
and not in the sense of somebody who's
unpredictable like non-predictable
okay now what are our subsequent moves
here let's take okay well this is just
total collapse
yeah that was not not the greatest thank
you savamenico for the prime
it's not good when you you know play the
whole game without developing
queen size
i mean that just went down the drain
very very quickly
okay so
g3 is one of several
good and in my opinion underrated
systems against this candy
all right so e5 is possible but if if i
remember correctly generally speaking
black
you know goes bishop f5 and then
and then puts the pawn on e6 and the
scandi uh it's not necessarily about
controlling the most amount of squares
but rather building up a very solid
center as john will be the first to tell
you but i think john is probably a
bigger specialist in this line than i am
and it might be that e5 is a reasonable
move as well thank you dr sputt
okay so anyways e5 castles bishop b4 is
already inaccurate it walks right into
a3
i would probably get the bishop out to
d6
but but bishop c5 i think a lot of
people would be tempted to play and what
should white do here
john bartholomew what should i do in
this position on the topic of
flexibility right yeah most of the time
you want to play d3 but if the bishop is
landing here
either you want to go a3 and rook b1 to
prepare b4 that's very valid
um but i'm thinking of another move i'm
thinking of d4
um the bishop kind of walks into this
and after ed4 and it for black is facing
very concrete problems white has two
very nasty threats one tactical one
positional can you guys name both of
them
well no both of them are sort of
semi-tactical
one of them is knight b3
and if you calculate further you'll see
that knight v3 doesn't merely trade
knight for bishop which is a very good
trade
i guess queen b4 stays in the game
because of queen b6 and knight a4 wins
the bishop thanks for the bits ozzy
it might not win a piece due to queen
before a3 queen c4 but
even if we have to take here and then go
bishop b3 and look how quickly we've
developed we've got the two bishops this
is also a good move white is just better
so
not so easy for black to develop and
probably the modest bishop e7 would be
the lesser evil
and that's when we go d3
then a3 rook b1
and ultimately the idea is before b5 and
the secondary idea is to open up the
center with f2 f4
um another you know very typical idea
but not before h3 just a word of advice
any time you play f4 and you're
fianchettoed
um what you have to be very careful
about is an idea connected with queen v6
and then knight g4 i see people missing
this all the time and it's actually very
nasty it seems very superficial
um and the issue isn't that knight f2 is
going to come it's that the knight can
also come to e3 in such positions
and and basically force you to give up
one of your bishops
uh which is not particularly desirable
you want to keep them in this position
so that's why very often it's it's a
good idea to prepare for by playing h3
to cover the g4 square
um
so that there's no shenanigans with
knight g4
uh red hot mama that's a great question
and that i could go on a die on a
tangent about that is it worth giving up
a fiance bishop for rope so you see a
lot of openings and ideas
that are hinged on the
on the fact that you give up
an exchange for your opponent's fiance
bishop and as you guys know when a
fiance bishop disappears from the board
just by definition imagine if the bishop
is gone there's tremendous weaknesses on
whatever color square that bishop was
controlling and i've won
right off the top of my head a couple of
games
uh with this kind of technique where my
opponent underestimated
you know the the potential
danger of
giving up his life a dark square bishop
for rook here's one example from
an old game of mine that i
that i just dug up
okay so i was 2300 when this game was
played
my opponent was 2200
and um
the following now black's opening was
really bad so i didn't win only because
of the sack
this was a close to ceiling this is back
when i played the close sicilian a lot
okay so black played rook b8 which is
a valid line
then e6 knight g2 b5
a3 stopping before knight d4 black is
kind of mixing up a bunch of ideas the
better option here is just to go knight
g7 but anyways
knight d4 castle sorry it was a slip and
after a5 i i played a move that i was
really really proud of
i was very proud of this move
because
i mean black wants to play b4 and keep
expanding on the queen side so i played
a move that looks like a tactical
blunder
and it's not necessarily that strong
objectively but it
temps black into accepting the material
after which he loses almost instantly
not a4 a4 there is b4 that doesn't help
who can
venture out on a limb and guess the move
no rook a2 is way too passive i don't
like this either because it first of all
gives up the bishop second of all it uh
forces the knight bishop h6 blunters the
bishop
e5 gives up the pawn
knight a2 is too passive yep uh
guy perez got it the move is b4
now the way this works of course that
first of all black can't really do this
because a bishop takes d4
my opponent was very excited though this
looks like a blunder that knight on on
c3 is no longer defended by a pawn and
he quickly took on e2 but i saw this
queen e2 loses the knight but no knight
takes e2 thank you dite and he
immediately grabs the rook which i think
is essentially a decisive mistake
and i think he quickly realized after
abab
that it's almost impossible for black to
to make a move because these squares are
so incredibly weak that black just
black's position simply collapses so let
me give an example he played it very
badly c takes before queen takes b4 if
he goes knight e7
one i can do many things maybe a
computer would hold on here but i can go
bishop g5 then bishop f6 and i mean
queen d2 queen h6 is already basically
an unstoppable mate threat
oh it's like two moves and it's already
made look at the domination of white's
pieces have
my opponent tried to patch up these
squares by going f6 but he ends up
giving up
a bunch of his center pawns
now not bishop f4 which walks into e5
but i played bishop a7
and think about how to establish the
nicest parking spot for the bishop that
bishop is a bit of a problem it's
dangling what should i do in order to
you know first of all improve my
position but also prepare a an outpost
for the bishop
yeah d4
rook d7
setting a trap bishop c5 queen takes c5
so i just move my queen out of the way
then bring the bishop back to c5
swing the queen to b3 attacking e6 and
now knight f4 and simply here he simply
resigned which is not a premature
resignation he was also in time pressure
um but the bottom line is that he can't
defend e6 and black's position just
totally collapses here totally collapses
king f7 there's rook a6
and this is just sad
and you might say wait a second
you know it's not really because of the
dark squares well yes it is you know
this bishop on c5 is uncontested and the
weakness of the dark scores led him to
play f6 which allowed me to win the game
in this fashion
um so
maybe that was a little bit too
elaborate but
just wanted to give one practical
example of what can happen now does this
mean it's always a bad idea to
uh to take a rook on a1 no and you
shouldn't take it to the extreme
um but it often is
um well i remember the game because of
this theme
so bishop b4 is bad and definitely he
shouldn't have taken on c3 i mean black
and castle here
and then we would have played rook
b1 cl smith asks is there any merit to
dc3 i was going to talk about that and
it's something i mentioned in the
previous speed run
uh
development is
a race in some positions and not a race
in others that's how i would phrase it
so what does that mean that means in
certain situations it is
crucial to develop quickly
situations where you can get a lead in
development situations where
your opponent is threatening to develop
an attack if you don't finish your
development
but here it's not like black white's
king is in any danger or like we need
the services of the dark square bishop
on the next move right nor do we have a
serious lead in development that we
that would require that would
necessitate
or justify weakening our position so
what it does the drawback of this move
is not only does it damage the structure
but the knight on e2 has no square so
somebody noticed
it's about the quality of development
most of the times just because this
takes one move longer
uh that doesn't mean anything and it
doesn't justify dc i hope that makes
sense
bishop g4 queen e1 and this position is
already very bad
rookie 8 before queen a6 makes it worse
he should go to c7 that sort of belongs
in the scandi then we go bishop b2 and
b5 with very serious pressure yeah we
decided to throw in h3 this should be
two and of course this is where black
totally collapses
and after knight bd7 and white is an
amazing position a4 and b5
but of course the most of the fight is
still ahead
um
so knight e4 94 bishop b4 and again if
f5 we of course play queen c3
and this is a good way to set a trap
rookie seven bishop takes that five two
pawns up with unstoppable threats on the
diagonal
how much does development defend on the
opening asks champ well it really yeah a
lot every opening has its own unique
system of development one nice way to
end the game here knight d7 how should i
continue here who can tell me
there's a tempting move that i know
somebody's gonna say but it's not very
effective
and then there's a simple move that is
so i think some people might be
attracted to this move but that's an
empty trap because then the king just
drops back to h a no need for that
rook fe1 or rook ae1 is good
rook a8
um
we're actually well the line i was
thinking
so after rookie 1 rookie 8
we can play the move rookie 6 for
example and then double on the e file
but i was thinking of the lion cafe one
takes takes this is check so rook ae1 is
more accurate and after knight f6 bishop
b6 is in fact a good move because after
king h8 there's this nice idea with
queen so i just wanted to show that
concept
that would be one way to end the game
anyways um after rookie four it's all
over just queen takes c4 i completely
don't understand this but
oh last thing after knight d7
uh there's a a move that
you know it's a blunder but
white gets lucky
uh bishop takes g7 might appeal to some
people king takes you 7 24 wins back the
night but it doesn't i talked about this
two days ago anytime you're forking a
knight you got to be incredibly careful
about allowing this
but it turns out that white can still
win back to peace with g4 g5 still
no need for that and what actually forks
the bishop at night is queen f5 that's
right and this wins the rook because
here in knight f6 this should takes up i
guess black and black bishop g6 but
obviously you can just take
[Music]